tras horas de incertidumbre la decisión
fue confirmada las tropas francesas
tendrán un mes para retirarse de burkina
faso es lo que anunció el portavoz del
gobierno de la ex coluña francesa este
lunes en la televisión nacional
afirmando que el país debe defenderse
solo
las autoridades francesas Siempre han
asumido el sacrificio que representa el
compromiso de Francia en el sahell de
forma general e incluso en burkina faso
es un sacrificio humano y más allá es un
sacrificio económico
la visión hoy es que son los burkineses
que van a asumir el sacrificio para la
liberación del territorio unos 400
militares que hacen parte de la
operación especial sábado están
actualmente desplegados en el país bajo
los términos de un acuerdo vigente desde
2018 actúan en conjunto con las fuerzas
burkinesas contra los grupos yihadistas
que controlan partes del territorio y a
menudo son autores de ataques contra los
ci sin embargo en los últimos meses las
manifestaciones se han multiplicado para
pedir La retirada de las tropas
francesas del país cuestionan las
intenciones de París y la eficacia de
Tales operaciones Sí si el trabajo del
ejército francés no nos satisface
debemos recurrir a otros socios que aún
puedan ayudarnos de lo contrario no hay
que quedarnos allí depender de Francia
que no puede o no quiere ayudarnos no es
interesante
la decisión de burkina faso sigue la
expulsión de las tropas francesas de
Mali hace un año que puso fin a la
operación bacán tanto mal y como burkina
faso son gobernadas por juntas militares
que se tomaron el poder por la fuerza a
medida que la influencia francesa sobre
sus ex columnas se degrada aumenta el
peso de Rusia en la región los países
occidentales han denunciado la presencia
de mercenarios del grupo Wagner en la
zona contratados por malí para combatir
a los insurgentes burkina faso no ha
confirmado ni negado haber tomado una
decisión similar